SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, I SHOULD
SAY, RIGHT UP TO YOU, ON THE
HOLDS IT IN, BARKOV, IN OVER THE
LINE.MES RIGHT UP THE MIDDDDNET.
WORKED UP WITH THE WING AND
SABRES BRING ITSCORES.
REACHES OUT AND PULLS IT BACK
IN, RIGHT THERE ON THE
JONATHAN HUBERDEAU PICKED UP THE
HUBERDEAU IN THE FRONT.
THE LEFT KNEE AND PUTS IT
HUBERDEAU, IN FRONT WITH THE RE
FORSLING.
MAKES THAT ONE STICK HISING
THE GAME.
>> RJ: REALLY.
THEY SCORE AND FLORIDA COMES
BACK 17 MARKS MAN INTO THE
POINT.
TAKES THE QUICK SHOT.
THE SAVE SHOT, THEY  POINT.
BACK TO THEY
SCORE AGAIN, DUCLAIR.
HIS SECOND
STANDING ALL BY HIMSELF.
HERE IT IS.
AND GETS IN THE P LOW.
TUCH SHOOTING ONE.
THAT'S KNOCKED OUT AND SCORE,
MAY HAVE MADE THE CALL, WATCH R
CENTER ICE.D CHECKING IT OUT
>> Referee: AFTER VIDEO
THEY SCORE. OF THE NET.
HE'S UNDER PRESSURE RIGHT THERE
BY THEIR OWN
END.
HUSTLING BACK. OF THE
NHL.
BACK HAND
WORK WITH.